number one movie in the country is gone
girl and people say people say the movie
features a brief shot of Ben Affleck's
penis now others say it's not really
clear that that's what you're seeing I
thought we should I haven't seen it
let's take a look now where's Damon
here's the clip let's see you haven't
called your wife's parents I mean you
can't get a signal in this building I've
been in here talking to you well call
them please Nick now
what I didn't see it why why would you
see his penis in that sink as you see
his penis in that scene that's why I
didn't see it at all I didn't sorry
Peter why I was really looking to what
if we slow down the someone said that's
it someone said if you really slow it
down
oh all right let's really slow it down
to see this penis hope you're enjoying
the show
I think I saw it I'm tired of going for
the - yeah yeah now it has a beard it
has a beard yeah I saw that yeah what a
gun is that alright and a corny yeah
he's happy
you